this is the first time I think Metallica
tour helped tremendously I think you
want the Metallica tour I bring that up
Jen I am sees a big difference saying I
am seed I was there opening him I don't
like say out in the open ur cuz it
wasn't that I opened in time to word
you're like the host yes
so no where's the Metallica so when you
got in their immediate Coast when you
showed up in the Metallica show I had
old pictures of Metallica on stage okay
so as you're walking in you're seeing
old metallic pictures then I had a DJ go
up from seven you can bring a birdie
video yeah or 7:00 to 7:30 I had a DJ go
up and he took all requests which I
programmed he first came to a solution
Pluto no no this is Metallica fans we
all got kids is to play for Van Halen
ac/dc scorpions Judas Priest that's what
you play then I would go up 7:30 to
about eight eight ten the crowd work
story in that group go in the audience
is so difficult in a theater and around
it's not an old-school iclal a lot of
old-school comics used to open up for
big musicians so it's it's nothing you
know it's back in the day with that yeah
and it was and it was it was in the
round which was pretty intense
so there's you gotta constantly people
around you go to the the one eight
nineteen yeah I go to that one I'm
afraid we need are you showing
sing-along oh this was a muscle okay if
we even hit this so I already create its
and some of them were game shows I bring
I bring Metallica fans on now here's the
thing see the audience Lars Ulrich told
me goes listen to my sooner he goes the
reason why we hired you is because is
Lars fan clearly he said identical
there's a reason why we hired you
because you know how to read an audience
you've been around a long time we've
seen you cuz you know Metallica's fans
you know the band because you're
professional create a show because but
the most important thing is you don't
have to be funny
cuz get a DJ get to whatever you need
tell me and I said well I tell you this
I'm gonna need screens oh I need screens
any good I said what about a live
Cameron he goes like this dude talking
to a king he goes hold on a second it
lifts up his phone just me the whole
time hey hey I've got Jim Breuer here
what's how do we get screens at a live
camera can we can do that is that in the
budget okay yeah and then he goes don't
be disappointed he goes we always hire
bands to open first nobody comes to see
the band's because this is why we're
trying this yeah and he goes it's a
bummer for the bands it's a bummer for
us he goes don't be upset if there's
like a thousand people out there because
most likely that's gonna be dude it was
from I would go out like oh my god
there's like there's 10 15 thousand
people already in oh my god
it was insane ever Jimmy I'm nervous I
know how could Jimmy so now I could do
that absolutely well then I would put
together things like this where it was a
sing-along
so his stories stand up sing-along game
shows it was an event I think you do
only guy who could pull that off
[ __ ] I log I'm not gonna lie to you
greatest gig ever ham I wanted you to do
it for six months
oh my god you two you were with that
from September to March you weren't a
last year at home you were with they
tour like professionals they do 17 18
days straight every other day okay so we
would let's say we did a concert in
Madison Wisconsin that night we get on
the tour bus yeah they go on their
Learjet and back to wherever they're
based out of Chicago
we then drive through the night to the
next town yeah you get your you get your
key and you go to your room and you're
off all day and then you don't have to
do a show until the following evening
right it was the greatest gig ever had
my I would do this the rest of my life
one of the biggest bands of luck
let me see this please yeah and plus I
love them like this is my good this is
my line of him imitating Metallica they
go the lead singer yours I sound like
yeah I think yeah it's perfect
listen play this is my favorite like put
instead they would go crazy with this
what is this part that's what this is
it's just a single tienda
yeah that's a sing-along so you just
finished up oh I just yeah I ended I
just said it's time for Metallica
because that's so about three seconds
about five seconds before this right
here well this is the beginning so I
said if you don't know the words do they
read them I have the lyrics up the whole
arena he's the only guy who'd do this
Jim and be successful look at the crowd
they're the guys my Dominican how often
they do I get goosebumps feel about it
hi
here we go what they love doing that
this is a wait right here and they would
go into but the biggest one was Pantera
which I didn't see coming the pit really
not so nuts wow they must have been so
happy with you being able to do this
[ __ ] and then time to get out there
they're like yeah do the best the best
compliment I got was it was three days
before the last day of the tour the
North American tour and Laura they go
Lars wants to see you in the food room
oh okay is he like the brains the
operation he makes a lot of decisions
he's he's definitely probably him and
James but Lars is definitely more active
I always say is a little more active
yeah
and he's very in tune and cares a lot
about what the fans think so he's
constantly thinking like that I think
that's not before every show they go in
a room and they rehearse for 40 straight
minutes playing songs before they walk
out in the arena and play over two hours
how cool is that every show man every
show discipline discipline complete
discipline discipline yes Hetfield I
went why do you guys why do you guys
like wood
he went gym you understand we all have
lives because we come here in separate
cars we're not hanging out of you I got
kids I have a family I can I have this
thing everyone's he goes this is the
only time before the show is we shut the
doors we come in the room what are we
playing let's rehearse this and this is
the only time we become Metallica before
we walk out a while nobody does that
what band does that this band right here
what I'm eating 40 minutes before I go
I'll be here 40 minutes you can be or
not hey we're gyms sounding like
Metallica and the guys like I sound like
that you know I'm talking about yeah it
was the icon MTV icon yeah I just saw
the other day man you know the coolest
thing MTV didn't want me they wanted
someone else and Metallica said no we
want a roller why it obviously was a
huge success I'm surprised Metallica
just doesn't keep doing it with him cuz
they're on tour now they're what this
was getting to so Lars I go meet with
Lars and he goes he's eating and he goes
do you think this would work and say a
stadium atmosphere anyway now and
they're going to Europe and I went with
an animal now my ego immediately went
you say yes and you'll figure it out a
week Iowa
Eagles say it's daytime it's in Belgium
now I uh you're in the business I said
to be honest with you if you made me
figure it out I could but I don't it has
to be a completely different show this
is different it's an arena it's indoors
I know everyone in that crowd and if I
don't I sort an American right is there
American they know me if they don't know
me they kind of like is that the guy
fraud I think I know I always this guy I
I would get off the stage and go up in
sections to approach people like wow
dude he's in the audience yeah
and so stadiums different animal
different piece
you can't control 80 to 100 just in
their attention on you they're coming to
see me Fiona Apple um I was hanging out
with her and she opened for Coldplay
when they were really huge yeah it was
really interesting cuz she said she'd go
out there and she was you know Fiona
Apple I mean she was great phenomenal
but she's first of all it's the same
thing a lot of people wouldn't be there
but even the people that where was
scattered it was just it was a huge
Stadium it would be rolling it wouldn't
catch up you couldn't control it's
impossible because there'd be pockets of
openings yeah and so they would they
would be talking the whole time so she'd
be singing and basically I'd be singing
it be like singing to a giant like it
open like yes Open Mic blowing a giant
right and in a loud car even even Rogen
said he did
I think Takoma 25,000 he's like just a
different animal man by the time the
word traveled your tags and stuff the
whole the whole rhythms difference not
made for that yeah let play this for
meet you I just watch this feeling it oh
my god Jimmy the only guy on the planet
can do this have you seen this B that's
mr. Swain of I'm so excited for it all
right guys look like a baby this just
like 2003 says three or hello Jim just
three 2003 does Metallica know how good
your answer is it like are you friends
already here no we're friends already
weird we're friends
cuz I got said they wanted a different
guy and gentle ahead
[Music]
oh my god because like I do the concerts
too warm sweating so dear itself so good
[Music]
is he from sweeteners
he's Denmark he's Danish he still talks
like he does this all the time just set
up is such a long set up so good Jim oh
my god oh dude this is [ __ ]
incredible
I'm telling you sound exactly I haven't
[ __ ] you do this I should jokes America
California he was on Rogen [ __ ] that
Scott is way too long
what say you talk about B's freeze 70
minutes got caught he got caught up down
the page somebody goes oh you're in DBZ
as am i and I was I was so excited I lay
on him and Rogen and then we talk about
B's 470 myth like wow have you ever done
that though if you ever gotten found
yourself in like a rabbit hole you're in
the middle of the ocean and you're
talking about something you don't even
want to talk about it but you you're in
if you're in you're like David I got a
finite way out of being a copy store
last night of coverage I get offstage so
we're talking about fighting and halfway
through I go oh I don't want to do this
let's go I gotta go
literally keys in mid-conversation go I
gotta go I just dipped out yeah he was
talking about fighting stage no no no I
got off stage
oh so I was asking about a certain fight
and we're he's probably 10 minutes in
the store and went oh you're wasting my
time I'm out of here man I can't ever do
that I have to sit there and listen not
me
way nice I'm taking I take deep breaths
among who've I'm never implied so I'm
gonna sit here with this person and
watch I'm gonna faint interest and I go
like this I go ha no way man no no you
go that's crazy
I can't I've wasted my life forever you
know we do we both do it when we don't
know what's on semi-interesting
oh yeah yeah both do that yeah he's a
great word is that's okay really yeah
it's so fun it's interesting yeah that's
a good take yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]